DACA.
STILL, IN THE END, HE SIGNED
THE BILL.
>> I SAY TO CONGRESS I WILL
NEVER SIGN ANOTHER BILL LIKE
THIS AGAIN.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO IT AGAIN
NOBODY READ IT.
IT'S ONLY HOURS OLD.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
$1.3 TRILLION.
IT'S THE SECOND LARGEST
EVER.
>> Laura: WHY DID NO ONE
READ IT?
WELL I REALIZE IT'S 2232
PAGES LONG, THAT'S ALL.
BUT THAT'S ALL THE MORE
REASON TO READ THE THING.
DO NORMAL COURSE BUDGETING
BILL BY BILL AND CAN YOU
ACTUALLY DIGEST IT ONE
DEPARTMENT AT A TIME.
BUT TRUMP SAYS HE SIGNED THE
OMNIBUS BECAUSE OF THE
DESPERATE NEED TO FUND THE
MILITARY AND THEN HE HAD NO
CHOICE BECAUSE OF A LOOMING
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
LET'S FACE IT.
IT PAINS ME TO SAY.
THIS THE PRESIDENT DID HAVE
A CHOICE.
HE COULD HAVE CALLED
CONGRESS BACK TO TOWN AND
MADE THEM PASS A CONTINUING
RESOLUTION UNTIL HIS
PRIORITIES WERE FUNDED AND
WE EXPLAIN THIS MESS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I TRIED IN VAIN TO WARN HIM
MANY TIMES THIS WEEK:  AN
OMNIBUS SPENDING BILL THIS
IS WHAT YOU HAVE TO KNOW,
LEGISLATIVE SCAM.
IT'S A BUSINESS AS USUAL
SPEND ORAMA AT A TIME WHEN
VOTERS EXPECTED JUST THE
OPPOSITE FROM A PRESIDENT
WHO CAMPAIGNED AGAINST THE
CORRUPT IN D.C.
AS I SEE IT RIGHT NOW
TONIGHT THE WALL IS NEVER
GOING TO HAPPEN.
BECAUSE, AS WE DUG INTO THIS
AND REALLY LOOKED INTO THIS,
THIS BILL DOESN'T FUND THE
WALL AT ALL.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
WE MUST DO BETTER.
OR REPUBLICANS DO NOT
DESERVE TO BE IN THE
MAJORITY.
>> Laura: WELL, VOTERS
ELECTED REPUBLICANS.
BOTH HOUSES OF CONGRESS AND
GAVE THEM THE PRESIDENCY TO
SHRINK GOVERNMENT SPENDING.
AND TO SHAKE UP THE SYSTEM.
NOT EXPAND GOVERNMENT AND
GIVE IN TO THE SYSTEM.
THIS IS LIKE CHRISTMAS FOR
DEMOCRATS.
I MEAN DOMESTIC SPENDING
GOES THROUGH THE ROOF.
CHUCK SCHUMER IS LIKE A CAT
WHO EIGHT THE CANARY.
HE GETS HIS PET RAIL
PROJECT.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, TOTALLY
FUNDED.
MEANWHILE, TRUMP GETS A
TRACTION OF WHAT HE WANTED.
AND ZERO AND I MEAN ZERO
FUNDING FOR THAT BIG
BEAUTIFUL CONCRETE BORDER
WALL.
ON MY RADIO SHOW THIS
MORNING, IN THREE HOURS, NOT
A SINGLE CALLER AND I WASN'T
TRYING TO WEED OUT CALLERS
OR MAKE IT ALL CUTE HERE BUT
NOT ONE WANTED THE PRESIDENT
TO SIGN THIS LEGISLATION.
>> GET THAT PEN AND VETO
THAT BILL BECAUSE IT'S A
PORK LADEN BILL.
>> AMERICA IS A FAMILY.
AND IT IS IN DEBT.
THAT MEANS SAYING NO TO SOME
FUN STUFF, SOME GOOD STUFF,
EVEN SOME POPULAR STUFF SO
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A
CHANCE FOR SURVIVAL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE ARE
WITH YOU.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE WITH
YOU.
BUT YOU NEED TO BE WITH US.
FIGHT FOR US, PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> THIS BILL SHOULD BE
VETOED.
I HAVE VOTED FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
I WAS A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
TRUMP TO STOP THIS SORT OF
THING.
AND IT JUST NEEDS TO BE --
HE HAS GOT TO TAKE A STOPPED
NOW AND STOP THIS.
>> THIS TRUMP DOESN'T VETO
THIS BILL, HE IS GOING TO
HAVE TO WRITE A NEW BOOK
ENTITLED THE ART OF THE
STEAL.
>> Laura: IS THIS THE
PRESIDENT'S FIRST SERIOUS
BREACH WITH THE BASE?
WELL LET'S ASK THE ONLY
MEMBER OF CONGRESS WITH A
PH.D. IN ECONOMICS,
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT GREAT
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA
DAVE BRAT AND ERIC BEACH IS
THE CO-CHAIR OF THE
PRO-TRUMP GREAT AMERICA PACK
AND MY AS IT
AND MY MS IT
AND MY MUSIT
AND MY MUSTAFA IS A
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ALL LATE
AT NIGHT ON A FRIDAY REALLY
IMPORTANT STUFF.
LET'S START WITH YOU
CONGRESSMAN BRAT.
IT BROKE MY HEART AND I MEAN
YOU COULD ASK LIKE MY STAFF.
I WAS REALLY DOWN TODAY.
I MEAN, I FELT PERSONALLY
REALLY DEPRESSED.
I WAS IN A FUNK BECAUSE OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
I MEAN, HE GOT OUR HOPES UP
THAT HE WAS GOING TO VETO IT
THIS MORNING.
THE MILITARY GUYS ARE LIKE
YOU GOT TO FUND THE
MILITARY.
YOU ARE GOING TO KILL THE
MILITARY OFF.
HE ENDS UP SIGNING IT AND HE
SAID HE WOULDN'T DO IT
AGAIN.
TELL US HOW THIS WENT DOWN.
>> WELL, I THINK YOU HAD IT
RIGHT.
IT WENT DOWN AND THE HINT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IS IT
WENT DOWN IN THE SAME WAY
IT'S GONE DOWN FOR THE LAST
10 YEARS IN A ROW.
LIKE GROUND HOG'S DAY.
WHENEVER YOU ARE RUNNING UP
TO THE DATE, YOU KNOW IT'S
GOING TO BE A DISASTER.
THAT'S YOUR BIG HINT, RIGHT?
WHY CAN'T YOU RATIONALLY
PLAN TO BUDGET AHEAD OF
TIME.
YOU KNOW YOU NEED NINE VOTES
IN THE SENATE.
THAT'S THE HUGE OBSTACLE.
WE DID A BUDGET.
THE SENATE WOULDN'T DO A
BUDGET.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT INCREASED
SPENDING ON EVERYTHING.
THAT'S A GIVEN, RIGHT IN THE
PRESIDENT AND LEADERSHIP
NEED TO GO TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BEGINNING OF THE
CYCLE AND SAY WE ARE GOING
TO GIVE THE DEMOCRATS THIS,
THIS, AND THIS AND HOLD
STROCK ON THIS.
IF YOU SHUT DOWN IT'S ON THE
DEMOCRATS.
WE DIDN'T GO THROUGH THAT
AND THEN I'M ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
A MONTH AGO WHEN WE DID THE
BUDGET, THIS WAS THE
SPENDING BILL.
BACK IN THE BUDGET THE
SENATE ACTUALLY WROTE IN THE
BUDGET THAT THEY WILL NOT DO
A BUDGET FOR THE YEAR COMING
UP IN 19.
THEY DON'T EVEN WANT TO DO A
BUDGET BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO HAVE A TOUGH VOTE.
SO TODAY THAT MADE NEWS.
RUSH LIMBAUGH COVERED IT AND
SEAN HANNITY COVERED IT AND
SO PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN GO TO
THE SENATE TOMORROW AND WE
CAN STILL GET IT RIGHT IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET IF YOU
DON'T DO A BUDGET YOU DON'T
GET TO DO RECONCILIATION.
THAT'S A BIG FANCY WORD BUT
THAT'S HOW WE WERE GOING TO
GET RID OF OBAMACARE UNTIL
THE SENATE YANKED THAT ONE
AND THEY OWE US.
THAT'S HOW WE GOT PASSED
THROUGH.
>> Laura: OKAY.
AND WE WILL GET TO DO THIS
AGAIN.
COULD IT BE A CHANCE HE WILL
NEVER GET A CHANCE TO VOTE
ON SOMETHING LIKE THIS AGAIN
GIVEN WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
IN THE U.S. CONGRESS WITH
SPENDING?
>> YEAH, I HATE TO GET MESS
MYSTIC THE PACE IS DEJECTED.
NOT ONLY SAY I WON'T DO IT
AGAIN BUT TAKE THE
INITIATIVE AND FORCE IT ON
THE SENATE.
YES, YOU ARE RIGHT.
THIS MAY NOT HAPPEN AGAIN
BECAUSE THE SENATE SAID WE
ARE IN THE GOING TO TO DO A
BUDGET THIS YEAR.
GOOD HELP US IF WE LOSE THE
HOUSE THEN IT REALLY WON'T
HAPPEN AGAIN.
WE ARE IN A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW TO HIT
IT OUT OF THE PARK AND DO
THAT IN THE NEXT MONTH
BEFORE NOVEMBER.
>> Laura: MUSTAFA I WAS
WATCHING CHUCK SCHUMER AND
PELOSI AND ALL THESE
DEMOCRATS AND DEMOCRATS THIS
WEEK WERE IN THE BEST MOOD.
THEY WERE THRILLED.
I SAID IF I WERE YOU, I
WOULD BE REALLY HAPPY, TOO.
AND I GOT TO HAND IT TO YOU,
I NEVER THOUGHT THIS WOULD
HAPPEN BUT I HAVE GOT TO
HAND IT TO YOU.
THIS IS WHAT WOLF BLITZER
SAID AFTER THE PRESIDENT
SIGNED THE LEGISLATION
LET'S WATCH.
>> HE SIGNS THIS, GLORIA,
INTO LAW 2200 PAGES, EVEN
THOUGH HE SAYS NO ONE HAS
READ IT, INCLUDING HIMSELF
WHY SIGN SOMETHING INTO LAW
THAT YOU HAVEN'T EVEN READ?
>> Laura: HE IS NOT GIVEN
ANY CREDIT.
HE SIGNS IT THE DEMOCRATS
LIKE IT BUT WOLF IS RIGHT.
NO ONE HAS READ THIS
LEGISLATION.
RAND PAUL WAS TWEETING SOME
OF IT LAST NIGHT.
WHO KNOWS IF HE EVEN READ
THE 2,000 PAGES.
THIS IS CRAZY MUSTAFA,
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS,
THIS IS GENERATIONAL
STEPPING OF THE NEXT THEFT
OF THE NEXT GENERATION.
YOUR THOWGHTS.
>> A TRILLION DOLLARS.
WHAT I LIKED ABOUT THE WILL
CHILDREN HEALTH INSURANCE
FUNDED FOR NEXT TEN YEARS.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
$250 MILLION FOR DEMOCRACY
PROGRAMS IN RUSSIA AND
SANCTIONS IN RUSSIA.
THAT GOT PASSED AND NOBODY
SAW THAT I THOUGHT THAT WAS
PROBABLY A VERY GOOD THING.
BUT I THINK REPUBLICAN
VOTERS HAVE TO ASK
THEMSELVES THEY VOTED FOR A
REPUBLICAN HOUSE AND
REPUBLICAN SENATE AND
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT AND
THEY ARE STILL NOT GETTING
WHAT THEY WANT.
SO, IN THIS 2018 ELECTION
FOR THE MIDTERM, THEY SHOULD
ASK THEMSELVES SHOULD THEY
BE VOTING FOR REPUBLICANS OR
SHOULD THEY BE VOTING FOR
LIBERTARIANS OR SHOULD THEY
BE SENDING A MESSAGE TO
REPUBLICANS AND NOT VOTING
AT ALL OR VOTING FOR EVEN
DEMOCRATS?
THAT'S WHAT THE REPUBLICANS
SHOULD BE ASKING THEMSELVES.
>> Laura: ERIC, I WANT TO GO
TO YOU ON THIS.
I HEAR A LOT OF SPINNING.
A LOT OF SPINNING.
THE MILITARY NEEDED A RAIDS.
WE ALL
RA ALL
RAIDLL
RAIDS -- A RAISE.
EVERY TIME REEND UP
MORTGAGING OUR CHILDREN'S
FUTURE.
ALL WE NEED IS WE HEY NEED
OF COURSE WE NEED THE
MILITARY.
THAT'S NOT AN ARGUMENT.
THAT'S A FALSE EQUIVALENCY.
THAT'S WHAT WE HEAR EVERY
TIME.
THE REPUBLICANS ROLLED THIS
PRESIDENT.
THERE IS NO BORDER WALL.
THERE IS 33 MILES OF LIKE
FIXING THE FENCE AND SOME
SENSORS.
IT IS A TRAVESTY THAT THEY
CONVINCED HIM EARLY ON THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO BE A REAL
BORDER WALL AND IT WAS NOT.
>> THEY CERTAINLY LIED TO
HIM.
ALSO, I DO THINK THE
PRESIDENT WAS VERY HEART
FELT WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE OUR
MILITARY IS NOT DEPLETED AND
THAT WAS THE FULL REASON WHY
HE AGREED TO THIS OMNIBUS
BILL.
SAYING THAT BILL FREEDOM
CAUCUS EVEN DISCUSS.
THAT I AGREE WITH MUSTAFA.
FOUR LEADERS TWO IN THE
REPUBLICAN AND TWO ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE WHO SAT IN
THE ROOM AND DID 2,000 PAGE
BILL AND DIDN'T TELL ANYBODY
ABOUT IT AND REPUBLICANS
THINK THEY CAN WIN
ELECTIONS.
I HEARD TALK TODAY THAT THE
REPUBLICANS CAN WIN
ELECTIONS.
I AGREE WITH DEMOCRAT
MUSTAFA AND WHAT HE SAID IN
TERMS OF THIS.
IF YOU WANT TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN INTO THE HOUSE OR
THE SENATE VOTE THE RIGHT
KIND OF REPUBLICANS, THE
RAND PAUL KIND OF
REPUBLICANS.
BECAUSE, OTHERWISE, WE'RE
GOING TO GO DOWN THIS SAME
ROAD WITH THE SAME PARLOR
GAME AND THAT'S WHAT'S
UNDERCUTTING THE PRESIDENT
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS.
>> Laura: BUT THE PRESIDENT
COULD HAVE COME OUT TODAY
AND SAID, YOU KNOW
SOMETHING?
I HAVE BEEN PAWING THROUGH
THIS BILL.
ON PAGE 734, LOOK AT WHAT IT
SAYS.
WE ACTUALLY INCREASE FUNDING
FOR DEPARTMENT WE SAID WE
WERE GOING TO DECREASE
FUNDING FOR.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE RIDICULOUS
PROJECTS THAT ENFORCE OTHER
COUNTRY'S BORDERS WHILE OUR
BORDER WILL STILL REMAIN
POROUS.
HE COULD HAVE DONE THAT.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN REALLY
BOLD AND IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
SENSATIONAL BUT CONGRESSMAN
BRAT, THAT'S HOW HE WON THE
ELECTION BY DEFYING THE
ESTABLISHMENT, THE
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM OF THE
MEDIA.
HE LOOKED RIGHT AT THEM AND
SAID I'M CALLING YOU ON YOUR
YOU KNOW WHAT.
AND HE COULD HAVE DONE THAT
TODAY.
BROUGHT THEM ALL BACK TO
WASHINGTON AND SAID START